[Music]
the division 2 is officially out very
exciting for fans of the original one
including myself I've been waiting for
this game for a long time we have
already been playing it for a few days
Eddie because we started it when the
early access got underway a few days ago
I think one of the biggest questions of
this game which I totally empathize with
being a person who doesn't tend to play
multiplayer games is is this game fun so
like if you're getting into it if you
don't already have a friendship group
who's super into the series if you're
not a fan of playing The Strangers is it
still a fun game to play on your own
absolutely it is but there's like
there's a lot that we can talk about
this but yeah my main takeaway after
playing this game for the past few days
for like 15-20 hours so far is that you
can absolutely have a good time playing
by yourself it might not always be the
ideal way to play or it might not be for
everybody but I personally have had a
really good time playing by myself the
main thing that gets me thinking about
whether or not I should all want to is
that the division 2 is so good with
matchmaking you because I definitely
know what it feels like to not always
have friends who want to play on my game
of choice all my platform of choice
which is usually PC and the division 2
is just fantastic at matchmaking you
into whatever it is you want to do and
that's especially with the addition of
the coal for backup button which you can
pop into your menu and select at any
point and someone can just answer the
call and just hop along to help you with
whatever it is you happen to be doing
and I find it really enjoyable and one
of the things I really love about
playing with other people is if I do
something silly if I go in gung-ho and
get myself killed that's not the be-all
and end-all I don't have to think about
where my closest respawn point is
although I will say one of the things
that's always popping off at games like
MMOs and stuff that I tried out is that
I quite like to be the hero of these
kinds of games and you lose that a
little bit when you're part of a group
but you get you really get it back again
when you're playing solo yeah you
absolutely do like so the thing I love
about playing solo it's not that I don't
like playing a multiplayer but
you know when you're playing solo like I
like to do things at my own pace on my
own terms it's just like what you said
you know when you're you know thinking
about a situation like where are you
gonna flank from what's the position
you're gonna take what's the angle
you're gonna take when you have a bunch
of random people while it might help you
overall sometimes they can be kind of
detracting force if you guys are not
unified and and also at the same time
like I like to have a plan I go in with
my plan and I execute it and yeah it
might be like a little bit more
challenging by yourself but like that
sense of fulfillment and reward like
when you finish and you're gonna knock
down a yellow enemy you know all by
yourself I think that feels really
really good it really does and there is
a random element and which some people
are a huge fan of I know generally I am
I don't really mind the kinds of people
I'm being matched with whether they're
people who want to open every single bag
like I do or whether they're people who
just want to go gung-ho and run I tend
toward fitting into whatever play style
the the people or person I'm with
decides they want to go with we're just
fine but it is really nice because this
world is it's beautiful the levels are
really interesting they're really
intricate arenas and being able to pace
them out as you say on your own
strategize and it's it's all up to you
it's a traveling on your own it's just
kind of an exciting experience to have
without just feeling like you need to go
along with what the people who are in
your team are doing I think the other
element here is like when you get into a
clan so you can still play solo but your
achievements you know get routed back
into your clans overall achievements you
can have that solo experience but also
contribute to something more meaningful
look personally I'm because I hate
respawning at random locations so much I
am the kind of person who will match
make for anything I do whether it's free
roam whether it's a side mission whether
it's a control point but there is a very
particular joy in doing these things on
your own that I really believe you don't
get as much in the multiplayer despite
how great the multiplayer is it's
something that Michael Higham said in in
his pay
on the how fun the game is in single
player on GameSpot and I think it's
definitely worth trying both to be
honest I think they both have their
place and it's great that the game
supports both as well as it does yeah I
mean I think that's my favorite part
about the game too is that while my own
personal preference might be to play
solo in no way does the game ever push
you down one or the other path it does
some things to encourage you to play
with other people there's no penalties
for not apart from maybe of potentially
a little bit more challenging experience
absolutely well if you guys want to hear
more about the division to our full
review is on the way so stay tuned to
game spot and check out the rest of our
coverage